Joseph gordon-levitt JGL otherwise not
as cool his back he's not returning his
Batman or Nightwing he's returning his
dog John and Don John he likes to use
this Long John John is a movie about Don
John Don John you only cares about a few
things funny thing is those few things
are the same things I curved he gives
about his body as you can tell look at
this wonderful physique his ladies as
you all know I get plenty of [ __ ] his
family their okay his church we all know
how much I'm a fan of Passion of the
Christ and most importantly he cares
about is porn I love a good porn out of
his name up a few of my favorite porn
stars right now katie morgan jenna haze
sasha grey you know they're all former
porn stars now was rotting vaginas
anyway dog johnny's guy is a porn addict
a porn addict who is in denial that he
is a porn addict now for some reason
i've done a lot of research on things
like sex addiction and porn addiction i
was worried for myself at one point
matter of fact if i was a porn addict i
wouldn't care probably just talk about
it more on the show i already do enough
talking about it but whatever but anyway
you know it's like i got interested in
it because how many people will tell you
that you know porn addiction and sex
addiction is just it's just a mental
thing but if you do something legitimate
research you will discover that porn
addiction is not just some mental thing
there's an actual addiction you know
maybe 95 percent of you are people who
are probably have porn on the other web
browser right now but anyway the port
edition thing was the main reason i
wanted to actually see this film i think
anything deal of important diction is
interesting because you get to learn at
the same time you can't get some good
visuals of some naked chicks
it's a strange film but it's not too
strange and it deals with porn addiction
but it doesn't make this subject matter
like super [ __ ] heavy you're not
trying to bash like a message in your
head or something it explores you know
very controversial subjects and a
rather comical way and a lightning way
an amusing way it's always entertaining
despite how dark the themes can actually
get so yes if you're young in who you
know wants to sneak in and dodge on and
catch some nipple a little bit maybe go
for it go ahead check it out so this
film has a lot of pornographic images
you don't need porn
you just need da job don't think too
this movie also features my favorite
porn site
w-w-w-whoa com click right here by my
crotch a link to www.opm.gov/life and
it's tarz the writer / director yet it
isn't distracting the whole time
watching the writer / director be the
main character in the film because
Joseph gordon-levitt's role is just so
immersive this guy knows donjon in and
out he embodies the role in such an
impressive way that you could swear it
was his only job on the film top left
you he just exudes such awesome [ __ ]
confidence in other scenes where he's
getting [ __ ] it was easy for me to
imagine you know if you switch out that
woman with me this guy could have just
been a complete joke just like a OneNote
character and he manages to bring a
level of depth to him and he manages to
actually make this guy who is still
funny rather a sincere charming
performance all around the acting he is
very solid Scarlett Johansson
Wow but I have a hot she was sometimes
she kind of looks like the animal that
John Leguizamo plays an ice age a sloth
yeah sometimes she does I [ __ ] that
sloth Scarlett Johansson you know plays
a girl of dawn John's dreams which is
apparently a high-maintenance
controlling [ __ ] if I was Don John I
would I would still you know want to do
things with this look at her look at her
looking good now pause the video and
masturbate she's great in this role
completely believable you know when I
saw the trailer I thought she was gonna
be like a really annoying OneNote
character too but she was actually the
some very very impressive performance
man I totally bought her as this person
you get lost in this character and
there's another player in this film that
I thought I was not going to be
talking about me Tony Danza man this guy
who awesome this dude always gets clown
Don but man he made me laugh so much
that I shat my pants it was embarrassing
I was with a girl I was trying to hook
up with rule number one
don't ever bring a girl you're trying to
hook up with to a movie about porn
addiction the whole y'all putting it on
thing over her shoulder doesn't work no
whipping out your penis doesn't work
either apparently [ __ ] your pants
well let's let's just say Ryan Ryan got
a few things right the dynamics between
him and Don John you know is easy he's
the father of Don John it's it's great
you totally buy this father-son
relationship julianne moore she's really
good in this movie too
kentley talk too much about her because
it'll ruin the film for you but she's
good and she manages to still be pretty
[ __ ] sexy I would still have sex with
his 89 year old woman I just assume that
when you're in Hollywood and you're a
woman after 40 you were in the high 80s
so that's refusing to write team I
really like this script a lot it's fresh
it's funny it's different feels familiar
yet original this those are getting some
criticism for you know having
stereotypical characters in it but as I
was watching this film I was just like
that's the point of the film look this
is just my own interpretation but I felt
like jiggle used New Jersey people to
communicate this story because it's
stereotypical you know macho New Jersey
guy is like the perfect thing to use to
communicate what it means to you know to
be the embodiment of a man you know
especially in America you know what the
average man feels like they should be
old some of us are just a little bit
more sensitive solvers some of us have
penises that are not the average size
some of us are a lot bigger than the
average says some of those people are
not me you know how like a manner
obsessed with you know getting buff
looking good hanging out with their
buddies talking about sports and [ __ ]
and then most importantly talking about
getting some why you got people like
Scarlett Johansson who are like love
addicts who are hooked on fantasy the
story deals a lot with imagery in the
Front's that we put up the main
characters just seems so detached from
like their own emotions from reality
that they look for happiness elsewhere
and stuff like porn addiction look
ladies in my opinion just let your guy
drag off it's human it's biological it's
just plain damn science as far as
history
jingoes it's done beautifully every
frame every feeling that's just
communicated it's all of what dawn John
is experiencing in that very moment
honestly with the way I work with a
cinematographer his editor this is
perfect brilliant I mean don't get me
wrong do you think this one has some
flaws you know even though it's a
90-minute film I thought a drag just
tiny bit in some spots in the last 30
minutes that I got a little too serious
this is a dramedy and sometimes drama
Dee's forget about the comedy part and
then just cover the draw part but even
in those moments it was always
intriguing I was always engaged but
honestly the ending I had a hard time
getting on board with you know I got the
arc of the character but at the same
time I thought as a film it sort of just
ended abruptly some people are gonna
like it I can totally see how some
people gonna feel the way I feel and to
those people you and I are gonna be
friends on Facebook but honestly the
first hour had me cracking up always
have me amused always have me engaged
and just purely fascinated by its
confidence we'll let me get straight to
the point here all I gotta say Don John
got it super right
alright guys thanks checking out my
review for Don John why don't you go
ahead school that comment box below and
tell me what is your favorite porn site
hey do you want to go ahead and follow
me on Twitter if you click the leave
right here
haha fake breasts of ladies that's for
you anyone see more in depth review of
Don John going to check out my show
called reasons to see that I do with my
buddy Jerry Jerry and I cut what about
art Don John's last but not least you
want to get updated every time one of my
reviews is out gonna click on this but
about my Don John to subscribed that's
right the 3rd John John I'll tell you
what things he likes blacks Taiwanese
Korean Mexican Puerto Rican Asian a
white girl